dans votre boule de cristal cette année
vous vous attendez à quoi
c'est difficile à dire parce qu'on se
trompe toujours parole de
microbiologistes et si le dr weiss ne
peut être plus précis c'est parce que le
vaccin qui réapparaît d'année en année
est produit selon une méthode qui a fait
son temps il faut aussi comprendre que
les vaccins contre l'influenza sont des
vaccins avec la technologie actuelle qui
ont une efficacité relativement limité
c'est à dire que quand on a 40 50%
protection en est content pourtant ce
chercheur croit que le vaccin administré
cette année devrait remplir ses
promesses
non pas qu'il sera plus efficace mais
parce que la souche h1n1 qui est en
circulation est plus faible pour le
moment ce qu'on voit ce que on a du h1n1
qui est à vraiment très très faible
fréquence mais qui sembla est en dessous
de ce qu'on voit partout non seulement
au québec mais au canada et aux états
unis et on sait qu'une saison avec du
h1n1 normalement le vaccin vaut mieux
protégés l'an dernier la société plus
virulente et la santé publique n'était
pas préparée l'an dernier ça a été une
saison particulière parce qu'on avait
beaucoup de la h3n2 donc là le vaccin
aux protégés contre ce sous type
d'influencé zola de façon je dirais pas
très élevé par contre on avait en même
temps beaucoup d'influx aux abbés et
pour cette partie là le vaccin
protégeait beaucoup mieux donc au global
on avait une efficacité autour de 40% et
le hasard nous a montré qu'on se trompe
souvent c'est à dire que dans le passé
regardez ce qui est arrivé avec le h à
1h 2009 on pensait qu'ils allaient pas
avoir de pandémie avec un virus nouveau
puis ça nous est sorti en pleine face
donc on n'a pas le contrôle sur quels
types de virus va circuler
en fait de la vie de ces deux
spécialistes il faut investir dans des
vaccins plus efficaces qui vont durer
plus longtemps
il ya des nouvelles technologies que ça
revienne mais évidemment ça va être plus
que ça va être dispendieux en termes
d'achat mais ces dates salins vous reste
espérons le être un plus efficace fille
d eux aussi logistiquement plus facile à
administrer et ça pourrait venir plus
vite que l'on pense
la compagnie medicago de québec
travaille depuis 15 ans sur un nouveau
vaccin à base de plantes
il doit être présenté le mois prochain à
ottawa à une conférence sur
l'immunisation
d'ici là il faudra se contenter du bon
vieux vaccin produit à partir de blanc
d'oeuf nouvelle grande inspiration en
espérant qu'il fasse effet ici catherine
kovacs radio-canada à montréal